before you share because Jennifer's
written a book called bonkers cool toy
if you like but I only wanted to if she
signs it well there's a picture of you
in it
there's yes oh yeah I depress apne index
as well okay how are you yeah yes yeah
but the thing about reading through life
is trying to kind of remember it all
there's been you actually lost your own
baby yes briefly yes I did
Ada and I were living in Richmond at the
time and I had three children I know so
many to keep track of yes and one
morning he got up and he went he went
and got the girls up the two bigger
girls who you know toddling around and
he took them down for breakfast and I
was to go and get the baby and I went
upstairs to the baby's room and the cop
was empty and I thought yes unusual
isn't it
in ourselves it yeah baby should be in
that car changing gym so I thought maybe
AIDS pictures up and taking it
downstairs for breakfast so I go
downstairs for breakfast the heart's
thumping a little bit you think this is
odd and my goodness says amazed feeding
the other two no sign of the baby and at
which point I'm thinking I should ask
him shouldn't I she actually asked him
then I think no he'll look at me like
people looks at Ingrid Bergman and
Gaslight they'll think you're mad never
had another baby
they're going to ask him I'll go back
upstairs I went back up to the baby's
room nothing I'm seriously thinking how
I actually I'm a gone mad
I've actually got a baby so I went back
down to my bedroom I sat on the bed and
as I leant down I felt this little lump
this is awful yes mums lettuce awful I
know you shouldn't do that but I was
breastfeeding her at night and she'd
she'd kicked herself I'd fallen asleep
obviously from tiredness and she had
kicked herself down to the bottom of
Bevan was sort of right under the duvet
and they just passed asleep still alive
she's dead
I can't square on this I didn't think I
had a chance you can swear on this
tonight what were you gonna say a shot
in hell oh hell because you know what if
I start complaining it's on I start
going down it's up and I went Tom
it sucked okay I got okay fine